i watched this one video lady she's 60
years old and uh she says uh you know
let me tell you guys about my life in my
20s the feminist movement was taken off
i joined it i went and became a career
woman and i did so well and all i wanted
to do was be better than men be better
than this and i bought into that
philosophy today i'm a millionaire today
i'm a c-suite executive today i've been
able to have all these shares i live in
a nice house i have all this other stuff
i don't have a husband i don't have kids
because i bought into this feminism
concept and she's now living in regret
so she regrets it because the value of
life you gotta invest into things that
have depth
depth is not
i met you we go home we have a good time
and then i never call you again there is
that's just a release that's just
science that's just biology but the
stuff in life that have depth
is is a lot of risk it's it's a it's
annoying it's it's challenging it
sucks your energy out of you sometimes
so you know she eventually had to figure
it out for herself but it's too late for
her not necessarily is too late for
she's 60 but she definitely doesn't have
the market values
she does she's not having kids well she
can't have kids so so so that's what i'm
saying sometimes the fallout that but
she bought into someone's philosophy
yeah yeah that's the problem we're
buying into someone's philosophy you
know i'm buying it you're buying it she
bought it you buy into the wrong
person's philosophy you lose your life
by the way yeah it's gone so i'll say
this right there's philosophy but also
facts and truth and at the end of the
day yes generally speaking you can't
find a way out however exceptions don't
make the rule yeah and as a result we
have to speak in generalities because
the general population they don't know
for the most part what they're doing so
just to be safe hey here's some facts
here's some data yeah you make yourself
aware and then we chose for yourself
yeah we're not seeing us to do what we
say we're just saying hey here's the
factors of data you make a choice but in
reality speaking you can see in real
time how women respond how we respond
and make for yourself a decision based
off of that and we also always talk
about you know probabilities versus
possibilities and when we debate with
girls a lot of the times they're so in
the possible like well it's possible for
me to find my guy and we be a power
couple and he's going to accept me and
my you know masculine attitude as you
would say when i was like yeah it's
possible but is it probable no actually
let's pull up this calculator and see
how prevalent this guy is and we pull up
the calculator and it ends up sure you
know they get this score they have a
cat-back score at the bottom all these
girls be scoring five out of five cat
bags perfect you know what i'm saying so
it's uh as far as like the delusion goes
so like is it possible to find this guy
that's six foot three a good looking
blah blah blah is gonna be monogamous to
you whatever potentially but is it
probable no another thing too is that um
like as far as like the dynamics you
were mentioned before is like women that
are power and they have um very strong
or the face of the um business or
whatever and the husband is background
though i've definitely seen those you
know um couples work and it hap it
happens uh every now and then what i've
realized is that most women don't want
to be in an authority position when
they're with a man they want the man to
lead some girls are okay with it with
okay i'll lead and i'll have this guy
behind me but most girls want the man to
lead so we tell guys listen just be
comfortable being a leader because
you're going to be most attractive to a
majority of women by being this way now
is there a woman out there that will be
okay with you being on the backseat
absolutely there's always those girls
there's a challenge with that here's the
challenge with it yeah sure is the
following and and adam i actually got a
question for you because there's only
one person here that has your experience
and here's what it is your experience
you've partied in multiple decades being
single so i'm curious to know what's
changed with you in a marketplace but
going back to that yeah we were talking
about what we were okay
we're talking about probability
possibility
okay so this is what's going to give you
the highest chances here's my experience
you give a guy a dating book on how to
be a player okay he reads the book on
how to be a player he reads the game
he's like oh you ain't that pretty okay
you know you know whatever it's like oh
wow well you mean i'm not that pretty i
i've had better than you oh my gosh well
one of the and i was like oh wow this
works you know calling her stuff that
kind of works man you know i like hey
mary how you doing my name's not mary
it's it's
oh i'm so sorry i i confuse you with
somebody else who's you you know so
that's okay yeah you learned that stuff
right
does it work like pat has never read
that book
but here's the point though here's the
point if you're acting
eventually people gonna know who the
real you is that's the problem so
meaning if i have to act like a gangster
but i'm a ranker i'm a i'm a you know
i'm i'm an interesting
bro you know what are you talking about
you ain't that tough why acting so tough
behind closed doors so you you can only
do that
if it's really you yes eventually if
you're gonna be serious with a girl
she's gonna realize you can are pretty
weak you ain't that guy so you have to
also balance that part out then the
divorce is definitely around the corner
because she married a different guy so
so for me when i went on a date uh uh
before we would act like oh my gosh
man you know what i was just walking by
smell those roses oh they smell so good
and you know i just love flowers my
favorite movie is notebook you know it's
just love story
fake fake fake fake fake fake listen
what's your favorite movie dude i
freaking love old school damn i love it
frank the tank friendly tank rank the
tank you know what are you doing
tomorrow i don't got to go to bed
okay you apologize to frank
so but the point is so jenna and i go on
a date yeah
and
i'm on a conference call coming back
she's listening to me on the conference
call it was probably the most heated
conference call i had and she's like who
the hell is this guy and i get off the
conference call i said listen if we're
gonna have series you need to see all
sides of me this is kind of me
okay all right let me see and then boom
we have arguments first week not waiting
six months to have arguments yeah then
there's all this other stuff like who
the hell is this guy said listen i can
act but eventually i know who i am yep
this is who i am yeah do you like it if
you don't please don't fight it because
this is kind of how i'm wired and and
i'm going to get better so that's the
part where i mean where if a guy tries
to act together
but it doesn't fit it's not going to
work because it's not my run and that
goes back with what i was saying before
the top of the show was talking about
how you know your competencies
accomplishments release the confidence
right and then you got to be congruent
based on that that swagger you are right
you got to be congruent yeah and girls
are able to like i said before they're
socially very socially receptive so
they're going to be able to tell okay
this guy's faking it after they deal
with you a bit right and that's why it's
very important to be who you are and say
who are you are and don't put on an act
like i get it like some guys have to
learn attractive traits whatever but
that's why we tell guys become the best
version of yourself because i have to
become the best version yourself you're
going to be in the best position where
you're going to be the most attractive
because you're going to be confident in
yourself and then when you deal with
women they're going to be able to feel
that it's going to radiate off you
without even having to try and then it's
going to be congruent and then you have
to you don't have to report yourself to
be somebody that you're not it's just
this is how i am and we tell guys all
the time you need to operate with girls
there is no negotiations we don't
negotiate with terrorists it's take it
or [ __ ] leave it you know what i'm
saying this is how we operate with girls
all the time we tell them like this is
how it is like we don't negotiate women
this is what i'm doing you can come
along for the ride but i'm not following
you and when i and i know a lot of
people are like oh my god there's a
misogynistic oh my god it's a woman
but what we say well the reason why we
say that is because we understand most
women not all but most women watch
assertive dominant man that's a leader
that knows what path he's on and she
wants to come along for the ride there's
a reason why 50 shades of grey is like
the most popular book is because that
man exemplifies so many different
attractive and arousing characteristics
that women look for and if a guy can
exemplify that and be congruent to it
you're going to be very attractive to a
lot of women and then on top of that a
lot of women find you attractive you
have a
abundance mindset your girl is going to
be in line because she's going to see
other girls looking at you we know the
importance of pre-selection when it
comes to women and i've always said it
when you have other women in line the
girl that you're with is going to get in
line and that's why it's so important to
be congruent like you were saying before
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]